6 30 wednesday morning let's start with
what's going on right now on u.s 95 this
will slow down your commute u.s 95
closed in both directions right now near
decatur a gas tanker has crashed and
flipped over bianca holman is live near
the scene with new information from
nevada highway patrol bianca
yes we actually just spoke with nhp they
gave us the latest update this happened
at around 4 25 this morning and so they
were told that it involves a bmw and the
gas tanker what is now turned on its
side this tanker was carrying more than
eight thousand pounds of gasoline so
very dangerous and we're told it's
leaking and that's why we are where we
are we're actually in the parking lot of
the meadows mall
set back far ways you don't see the
flashing lights too too close in the
background because of the danger that
could happen if that leak was to spark
fire it would be a very big explosion so
they want to keep us safe they want to
keep people around here safe we've
actually seen of course nhp responding
there's definitely several fire crews on
scene where that tanker is trying to
make sure that area is
cleaned up and also again people are
safe now the individuals involved we're
told no one was taken to the hospital
the driver or those that were in the bmw
we have not confirmed just yet how many
people were in that vehicle but once we
know that information we will keep you
updated but the good news is that
neither no one in either of the truck or
the vehicle was taken to the hospital so
again we're set back quite a ways those
areas on the 95 northbound and
southbound has been closed in either
direction so we're actually going to
send it over to nate tannenbaum a
traffic anchor who has a route that you
can use to get around this absolutely
and this is a great example of teamwork
in our law enforcement community you
have nhp on scene you have las vegas
fire on scene metro police also helping
out so now the rest of the freeway
system is not bad but when you shut down
a big portion of a major freeway in a
big city it's a big deal so from the
spaghetti bowl basically over the
rainbow curve that is a no-go here's a
live picture from our traffic camera
tons of emergency equipment here's a
photograph that bianca took before they
moved her that is a gas tanker on its
side so how do you get around if you're
coming from the east side of town and
you have nothing to do with that part of
town you're good
i would use the 15 to go north or south
maybe get over to rancho up to
washington or lake mead rancho down to
charleston or sahara i believe decatur
is completely closed you might have
access to jones but this southbound 95
boy this is going to turn into a parking
lot and it already is now back to
washington so south 95 once again the
freeway is closed okay so you want to
get off at lake mead uh work your way
east or west and then down to charleston
or sahara take lake mead east to
wherever you're trying to go because the
freeway is going to be closed for quite
some time we're going to be keeping an
eye on this we'll
continue to keep you posted both on air
and online